we will make our medical supplies
right here in the united states a busy
week of high profile events for
president trump
culminated with his announcement early
friday morning that he and first lady
melania trump
tested positive for coronavirus
though it's unclear how he might have
contracted the virus or who he may have
infected
images from his travel over the last
week show little adherence to cdc
guidelines of social distancing and mask
wearing by the president and his inner
circle
raising questions about how widely the
virus may have spread in the highest
levels of american government
on saturday september 26 the president
was in washington to announce the
nomination
of judge amy coney barrett to the
supreme court
i stand before you today to fulfill one
of my highest
and most important duties under the
united states
constitution the nomination of a
supreme court justice
later that day he went on to a campaign
event in middletown pennsylvania judge
amy coney barrett to the united states
supreme court
he returned to the white house late that
evening he went golfing in virginia
sunday morning
and he held a news conference in the
evening to address reports about his
taxes
actually i paid tax but and you'll see
that
as soon as my tax returns it's under
order
on monday the president gave an update
on the nation's coronavirus testing
strategy in the rose garden 150 million
later that afternoon he appeared for a
photo op with the makers of a new
electric truck
the motors engines are in the wheels
on tuesday the president flew to ohio
for the first presidential debate with
joe biden
irresponsible the way in which he is
look i mean i have a mask right here i
put a mask on it you know when i think i
need it tonight as an example
everybody's had a test and you've had
social distancing and all of the things
that you have to but i wear masks when
needed
when needed i wear a mask he flew back
to the white house that evening
on wednesday the president flew out to
minnesota to attend a private fundraiser
with senior advisors
including hope hicks
and then to speak at a campaign rally in
duluth
hello everybody hello duluth hello
on the flight back to washington senior
advisor hope hicks
started showing symptoms according to a
person familiar with the matter
on thursday trump flew to his golf club
in bedminster for another campaign event
soon after he returned to the white
house it was reported
that senior adviser hope hicks had
tested positive
trump spoke about the diagnosis in an
interview that evening with sean hannity
things happen
i was surprised to hear with hope but
she's a very warm person with them and
she
she knows there's a risk but she's young
and i just
i just went out for a test they just do
it it'll come back later i guess
and the first lady also because we spend
a lot of time with hope and others
in remarks at the annual al smith dinner
that night he expressed his optimism in
defeating the virus
i just want to say that the end of the
pandemic
is in sight and next year will be one of
the greatest years in the history of our
country
just before 1 am friday morning the
president tweeted that he
and the first lady had tested positive
by the end of the day on friday the
president's physician recommended that
he go to walter reed
he left the white house and boarded
marine one